hey everybody I'm Chad nice and you're
on the toilet right now this just got
weird welcome to hashtag news so
President Obama gave the State of the
Union address on Tuesday and while we've
had some good ideas on how to improve
the country it just really wish she
would have addressed a few things that
would have actually made a difference in
my everyday life hey Obama you tried
your best with your state of the union
address you did okay but I wasn't
impressed so I have a few things to sig
ass like if you exercise every other day
the health care costs you don't have to
pay if you can't get a job even with it
to creek then your student loans are
voluntary you don't hire cops if they
seem like you're racist maybe if they
voted for you then they pass the test
you only have to tweet if you want to
vote but use your instead of you're an
interim folks more importantly I want to
end the very annoying GP trend of paying
for an entire cable package when all I
really want is HBO even more
specifically a game of thrones only
Shannon I don't know why I'm getting so
mad I do have my sister's HBO Go laga
but [ __ ] Jay sing the song sorry if your
famous photo shop isn't allowed life
your maid and you can so it levels out
and every hot pic to post must be
accompanied by one that's fugly tel
apples not making their iphone skin
you're kidding other phones body image
issues not cool and instead start making
a cell charging battery how are they
supposed to do that I was a NASA make
elders read urban dictionary so they
know it's on fleek and who's a big if
you post spoilers there's no protection
you're gonna get the full injection cuz
you ruined breaking bad for me mark and
for that I will never forgive I mean my
girlfriend also made out with you but
that's neither here nor there yeah sorry
and that's my State of the Union
you
well that's it for this week's episode
of hashtag news make sure liked this
video you really wish there was a game
thrones channel comment if you have any
other ideas that make our lives a whole
lot better if there's one thing we can
all agree and that's what everyone
should be subscribed to new media rock
stars Ellen grad both parties can agree
on something I'm Chad meats and I'm
gonna go write a letter to my
congressman
mmm